a silent cry for help read rags pieces
of cloth even shirts signaling that
inside behind those windows there's a
family need they have become a potent
symbol of the effects of the lockdown on
the most vulnerable Colombians a visible
measure of the daily rise in poverty and
hunger Miguel Gomez father of two young
girls says the rags have multiplied
across his neighborhood home to many
people displaced by Colombia's internal
conflict like most he lost his work and
saw how his pantry emptied out we are
down to eating once a day at the
beginning neighbors too helped us with
some food but now they also ran out the
government says stay in stay in but we
can't eat boards or tiles the government
and municipal authorities say some help
is on the way a first payment of a
hundred and forty dollars for each
family in need but no one here has
received it yet so some of built
barricades with stones and burnt tires
this sign says they're starving people
to death we are hungry there are babies
dying of starvation because the aid
hasn't arrived I'm here in the morning
at night at all times and nothing is
coming helping the roughly 20 million
Colombians who work in the informal
sectors requires a colossal effort on
part of the government and at least
until now it seems like there simply
isn't enough help or it's taking too
long to reach many of them the city of
Bogota says it's spending 55 million
dollars in aid delivering bags of food
door-to-door yet despite the efforts the
mayor recognizes the delay we already
sent money to 280,000 families and 1.7
million bags of food and even with such
a monumental operation in three weeks we
are still missing people and there's
another national disease complicating
the efforts corruption government
watchdog entities found evidence of
money embezzlement
thousands of contracts meant to combat
the crisis I think that what we have now
in Colombia is actually three pandemics
the coronavirus hunger and corruption
what this virus is showing us is just
how inequitable and unjust our social
and political system is a crisis upon a
crisis that seems impossible to keep up
to as the needs continue to pile up
alison ramp et al Jazeera Bogota